so your life dude so perhaps for life
how do I sit in business
alright so here we are so in just a
minute here this should pop up on the
screen
yeah and we'll see that we are our going
life and so probably not a lot of people
are watching it but this is going to be
a stream with vara Cobian who will be
here we were hoping he could be here
right now at 3:30 but he'll be here in I
guess 45 minutes or so so we're gonna
mark a little bit of time until he gets
here but when he shows up he'll
definitely be the one sitting in the
seat playing the chess so again we're
also kind of testing things at some
point I'll need to see let's see how it
looks so we still got the chat thing
we're working out some of the technical
issues but where we at probably one
person because we're not on my chest yet
but if you're watching send us a
challenge something like five minutes or
something I'll play you until VAR gets
here I'm here with Danny Machuca and
Dennis of the Roo in the room so you
know you could also play mr. LaRue we
got a challenge half a minute are you uh
are you a 30-second specialist take it
just it might be silly something like
five minutes is optimal
well yeah this guy's doing it he we're
not even on the thing yet it takes like
one or two minutes to end up right here
yes but uh there's the same guy no
challenges you want no way no challenges
okay yeah three minute sure okay let's
just get this thing going
we'll play a three-minute game we're
still provisional here
what does dance that were like Sicilian
I want to play like knows the room
that's my goal he plays here
I know Dennis nope I give him
whiskey give up resign won't play the
theoretical sharp good but oh my space
is Vonage so he's a bit of mouse yeah
yeah he meant to cancel oh sure do you
give you get Mouse lips or no mmm
I'm somewhat merciless I have to admit
yeah I will though I'm did developer
stuff yeah yeah I'd like to do it when
it's like ultra obvious obviously didn't
mean but that that's a Danny huh
yeah I wonder if we're on the main
whatever on the main screen it's never
stopped me before
we have seven people so are we I wonder
if we're on the live chess on the my
chess to make it up Danny no yeah no
this is horrible
so getting crushed getting crushed here
you're fine I'm fine
no no he's great yeah we're on there Oh
perfect
he's also like okay good yeah so
everybody they're looking for var he
will be joining us what's the countdown
in some number of minutes yeah 45 or so
45 minutes or so and then yeah you won't
have to watch positions like this hi
Teta 64 hello that's 100% what I did so
how is if you're in the chat please let
me know how everything is the the volume
that sort of stuff just want to make
sure Williams good for you guys we got
the the Yeti bike again seem to work in
the past yes so see this is useless a
30-second delay but yeah you can see
you're yourself there what are we doing
still quite bad for me I mean the chest
part other things are find don't check
me I hate getting checked
I'm checking might be bad yeah except
for night takes my my do diddily good
all is good perfect
that's what this guy says what if all
this is really this is really bad
it's awesome this is awesome oh yeah
this feels good
there's no way I'm taking my bishop
might be quite strong and just bring a
rope in check maybe okay good all right
good to see you JJ chess oh how come
everything's getting like deleted and
stuff yeah we're like this is a three
minute game all right some checkmate oh
it's they're really worried I'm taking
my dishes JJ JJ from so JJ only Monday
yeah yeah of course he's watching our
stuff he's probably hoping for far but
it's good to see you JJ
hopefully you're in the cube when var
shows up so he's in our time zone so he
knows it's at 4:15 yeah good we got the
photo so we don't following there's no
noise right yes yeah no JJ for those who
don't know is a grandmaster at SLU which
one I trust in us the roof so don't lie
to me good fit where do I anti trust you
you guys have started streaming yeah um
some point rook takes this is just gonna
terrify me at some point but I'm not
there yet not scared yet I'm working up
to being really scared now is there it's
also about just moving fast yeah well
fast flight people this is this is my
kind of chess here trade I got this
yeah so it's like we're this is like I
don't know trade
okay
hopefully you're looking at your watch
to see is this over yet this is
captivating yes this is good
have we flanked him yet all right more
random okay what's the trick
random loose don't attack me baby pawn
will you take my room I don't know
this is hopefully just some flagging
operation here this actually is really
art for me to move on your mail session
to play a special one games
we gotta play well today we've the GM
next to our name and GM's are watching
us so we gotta play there we ought to we
won't but we ought to
yes all right thank you some ham 777 for
the very first game they want us to what
time did should be one five minutes is
the best and yeah again we're just
waiting for a bar to show up oh we got a
2005 Oh
you also could challenge Dennis the rule
if he's up for it and he is up for it
okay tell me Dennis before you can play
now yeah remove dude there's a bit much
that's the problem
I don't know we had 64 in climbing it
was like 10 most popular responses to e4
d for something like that yeah I did a
lecture I'm something like that okay
waiting for yon Oltmanns give you a few
more seconds here
well if you saw my last game you let me
see b4 alright sorry Jana Ultimates
alright try again
fire-breathing dragon just subscribed
blindfold billion I hope you smelling
vine folded here we go oh cool
fire-breathing dragon welcome aboard
that's interesting then the sound here
is like turned off or something just
like how it was yesterday cuz you didn't
hear it pop up on your side okay so this
is the thing and blacks supposed to be a
little bit better why yeah I always get
this position so
why do I got here haven't played this a
long time
I've learned quite a lot of blitz games
here at the club with this particular
one so I've had this position several
times
[Music]
oh yeah you guys I just have more
bishops
and everything should be okay from here
and if you like this clean it's not
normally here because normally when I'm
on the square at some point a night
chases me away so we never see what
happens
there's no 95 great tricks here for him
yeah 95
so hopefully there's no the Tricky's
here my loose piece trained fellows who
do I love to trade everyone knows to
calculate really deep stuff here that's
the sound of deep calculation by the way
[Music]
everyone's so serious in the room today
it's a bit of a letdown
I guess everyone is prepped for far
you're having fun
I'm just gonna leave this here alright
there it is it's about time that thing
attacked me I knew it would do I want to
trade Queens
I love trading
so if he ever plays that I move like
before hopefully I can use the square as
a sort of outpost here for my rookies
what do you think about a Carlos
streaming also MVL said he would be
starting now to be very exciting I would
like to see MDL do streaming Caro is
pretty good
I do enjoy listening to him doing his
streams how do we challenge we're on
light chest org challenged st. Louis
Chess Club
I like 5-minute challenges when markets
here he might like something else
I was wondering here if I have to move
Bishop to a4 does that attacks rook the
rook moves away I take your night if any
Knight takes me I take your wreck that's
exciting
challenge st. Louis chess club that's
the way to do it so yeah I haven't
talked to far about it I don't honestly
know where he is right now he's
somewhere probably super prepping for
all you guys but when he shows up he'll
pick whatever time control he is into
and we'll see what he's up for okay so
this nice can go back somewhere that
defends the bishop I will then attack
his night which is defending the bishop
hopefully a money
but okay everything seems to be going
well in terms of the quality so we're
still having the same issue you might
see if we're under a little bit of
construction here we got the chat window
and that little thing that's hovering
over the chat room that's supposed to
fill up with chat comments and so I was
actually hoping Bensimon would be here
so we could would he would he know more
about those he doesn't know anything
yeah he shouldn't know anything more
than Danny Machuca right he doesn't know
what the software is called okay but uh
okay we got great minds working on it
yeah well Corner Monday said all right
we did it
did you want to step in here yes all
right I feel good about that game first
game doesn't joke but uh we'll let
Dennis the roof pop in is there anything
you wanted to do during the stream this
time for in terms of fixing up the
software yeah yeah click on the source
mmm very choppy hold on okay well you
said his name already
hey you don't recognize any of these
names there's been a lot of people all
right have played but in general if
you're active in the chat notice your
name it will probably play yeah just
because Danny's here
so what is your feed a rating my feet
are rating is 1970-something
I'm not a few a rated Dennis the roux is
not few decorated I'm on stream I assume
we're talking about dance through you
shouldn't have admitted you weren't FINA
rated enough cracked oh seven you're on
the radar we will be looking for you
this guy doesn't want to play okay Barry
chop you yeah so you got to abort then
at the X go Dennis all right that's
gladiator chess he's got you back all
right
that's up to you okay yeah in general
rainy games are better play whoever
though why don't we keep getting blank
yeah okay well good wait a minute I
thought you were Sicilian guy no I just
play the French well I remember you take
that guy there you go for knocks no time
for that gonna lose your bishop as fast
as possible yeah this is a Danny Machuca
specialty all right so that's good
good to see you go get glad you're
having a nice evening I said what's the
evening hey guys for all we know you
could be talking about an activity does
very early on in the day
why play low rated players we're just
playing who's there
i I picked the 2 top people I could find
I the two top people who can beat and
then we'll take a very funny but I've
can't read that one okay what do I need
- well said that's how you play ninja
style what time is it in st. Louis it is
348 and part will be here at 4:15 so the
math on that is impossible but if you
get a calculator out
you'll know when FAR's gonna be here
black does not look like he is used to
using a mouse nope
are you sure hard no this is this weird
master Dan yeah right I struggle with it
as well so he's challenging us too fast
time controls is a recipe for beating
ultra slow oh my god I got this stop
making fun of me please I'm I'm very
sensitive
please trust yourself
yeah you Grandmaster next your name
you're strong today you've never felt so
strong the club shares the account yep
gladiator justice right so yeah and we
will be having a GM on our account today
which is very exciting so stay tuned
wait about 25 minutes or so and bar will
be here and when he shows up we're all
out of the chair running away running
you're going to look at a new hearing
greater than this you're the best
no you don't see I thought I was doing
bad once and then Danis tumor treatment
because I know I've been watching since
2014 I will move out to st. Louis not
long after I graduate college this year
and we'll get to meet gladiator chess
you're in person very exciting hey ex
villager we've seen you before yeah it's
not a normal Mouse it's really weird
do you want a weaker Mouse you're joking
that was nice to fight this cool super
ultra mega this is an interactive stream
on Twitch yeah be true Yannick student
good to see you again
Wow after talking so much you were ahead
on the clock yeah that's what I'm here
for do all the talking I'm really here
just to talk to chat I'm not here for
the chess that's one we had to bring in
Denis learner today so yeah good to see
a lot of people some new people some old
people we've seen before reading the
chat I know that's kind of the problem
how are you gonna focus on the chest
someone needs we need a grandmaster here
focused on chess and one guy talking to
you guys once about new prank is my name
like if you like a little increment sure
one of us will playing you knew Frank
you're on the you're on our radar
all right what's happening mr. Lee real
mmm I'm honestly not sure why his wife
is a little bit better here whites a
little bit early I agree yeah okay can
you see we got this yeah as long as I
stay up on time sure stop don't you
better believe laddie ater [ __ ] is my
name okay mr. gladiator chest will be
coming here did GM been fine cold break
all the chairs you got to get one cherry
man I know there's a guy next to me
though I'll get a chair
it's the kite off screen yeah um no that
fine golden brick why are you chairs too
much
hey give me mooks okay you don't I just
thought only make you worse through the
best all right no Kramnik student will
but please don't send this moves during
the game yeah yeah yeah who's in like
assessments that sort of thing that kind
of want to avoid I wanna okay
feels like slightly cheating it seems
fair for those in the room for those in
the room feels the you know kind of a
part of the general experience that we
help each other but uh outside help this
is not particularly yeah okay I'm with
it one yourself do you nasty past pond
on the outsiders it's okay guys Michael
regulars bars here
yes so for those of you watching this is
I guess our third stream for those of
you watching for the first time this is
something we're gonna get all of our our
GM in residences and we always have one
on staff all throughout the year we're
gonna get them all in here streaming
chests so and I think we have a name now
for our segment - it's called play the
people that I was thinking were qiyam
thank you very much
I believe his thing went to charity so I
guess people can give these these chairs
these hundred bits Cheers and it goes to
charity which is super awesome cool I
also went to directly relief yeah very
cool thank you very much
also my like chess please don't give us
things like evaluations
so I think if we somehow turn the volume
up on here we'll actually hear it when
they Danny so I think if we turn well
okay that's all and we can figure it out
if you out there I heard it slightly
where is var when is Mark coming thank
you for the donation remin 12-bar will
be here in approximately 20 minutes
until then we're just marking time if we
turn up where do we turn up the crime so
we hear there they probably are hearing
it yeah what is on this guy yeah okay
that's the size if we can hear it I
assume I assume you guys hear it also
good we're getting lots of uh you've got
a couple donations re the one guy gave
to charity
thank you
yeah so does she feel okay check very
setting
Lily thank I might get my anger yeah um
so let's put him somewhere that way
maybe isn't hanging and then Brooke I
don't know there's nobody right so just
make sure you flake people yes sir
we're not here to like win with good
quality chests that's what bars coming
in to do we're here to just win I like
it by any means
takes course that's why I
Wow all right that was very exciting
until that last move there yeah well
played by Raisin Bran crunch thank you
okay am I getting up yeah this is Frank
noob guy okay
noop Frank sure sure we've got some
other good ones I saw kramnik student
there for a second you want to get
around to him it's been a French day so
let's play this although in our first
round of this didn't go so well what
time controls approximately five minutes
nice scheme Thank You granik's dude okay
so I think we've been over this I think
the Emer RFC is not super good against
this particular set up by black due to
this bin this night might be hanging
thanks guys who are you you're playing
to befriend cook well this guy still is
s fish I don't have this we're just back
I'm a claim every night yeah someone yes
got your chest yes but then I got to
test my upper piece skills not always
easy we'll see if we can manage
big decision take nothing that would
shock him he's attacking your stuff and
you didn't save it yeah
now I'm taking lots more stuff I
attacked your rook sir Wow I can also
take your pawn also might be strong this
is simple keep it simple
you release that I agree without though
g5 totally safe it's not necessary
though where where the optimal square
are streamers Jonathan Schwartz is
playing right now never heard of hey he
played a good move
that's upsetting I didn't see that
coming I wasn't I wasn't watching he
cheated if only my bishop all right yeah
yeah well I want to give some back he's
a generous guy too much too generous
does anyone play French Blackie six
followed by C six rather than C five
no C 5 breakers to manic even
oh wow that's ugly
well you are you are already up a piece
so I should go I don't know I kind of
like t7 because you could recapture on
f6 but yeah a 95 looks kind of scary
let's hope it doesn't hear that say
there's 2 seconds off the clock by mu 15
I think yeah we're getting trolled this
is 5 2 it's also casual so if I lose
it's also whatever what's your favorite
time control for a challenge 5 oh I
think we're all agreed on and then barb
might want something else
is it Kobe yes so Cobain is coming in
shortly we're just warming up warming it
up for anything okay someone's got a
warm up we got to play a bunch of bad
loops get him out the way so you can
come in and play all the good ones I had
the pleasure of having dinner yeah so
far should be here in about 15 minutes
so if you want to save your challenges
for him by all means we will not be
offended what is he gonna do he's gonna
something bad to me at some point I
don't know I'm just gonna take this
you're still not Material yeah I just
trades to just train okay does my
aggressive tone right
I refrain from - oh yeah was a bit fast
he can take it but he's being - okay
well we're also talking and goofing
around and looking over there we're not
really whatever they focused on the
chest I'm also gonna be interested to
see what VARs general attitude is cuz I
assume he's gonna be slightly different
than us we're just goofing around but he
might take the chest seriously so you
guys you better bring your A game
she was attacked
I don't know I'm cheating um 300 all
players you play three oh sure
three I was manageable if I did play one
three autos it's difficult with this
mouse I won't talk a lot you have to do
all the talking yes
No Eric is coming back sometime no
anything
yeah he is traveling a ton to my to my
knowledge that's what he's up to these
days I believe I have a tactic here
followed by taking huh the idea being
ropes coming in what days of the week do
you guys think you'll stream regularly
so at some point in this upcoming year
it'll be the situation I'll probably do
Tuesday's someone's gonna do Wednesday's
not sure who could be does the row could
be Rhine Chester once they might be the
just general some Chess Club employee
probably Thursday's seem to work out
best for the gym so that's when they're
gonna actually come on and rock the show
and if all goes well Friday's will be
Mike comer day that's the day to really
get excited for it yeah yeah GM's but my
cover we have to get we haven't hooked
him yet he doesn't know of my evil plan
to get him to stream regularly but uh
but in general so the next stream after
this will be on probably Tuesday at noon
Central Time so what do you do in life
except for chess you want to turn here
let's go all right Thank You Newt Frank
did I play very choppy already no that
was somebody else you did yeah we played
choppy Kramnik student 2018 oh you might
be too strong for me okay right Cobre
Pulido three to standard 28 don't worry
about any GM Ken where streams that also
would be interesting there's a lot of
the the local celebrities I know if
Mario's here bring Mario down the fans
made whenever oh you blundered upon you
lost okay whatever
whenever he's here mr. Ken West we'll
ask him for streaming we'll ask him
people would like that
I was away when you accepted my
challenge very choppy okay yeah no
worries
throw it in there again we might pick
you up again yeah Thank You Luka for the
game
you shouldn't have dropped a piece in
the opening agree my comer I watched him
beat a kid six times in a row when $100
bet good job Mike sounds like him yeah
yeah watch everything Mike's none
there's nothing like stun that wasn't
entertaining all right but you are the
you're the more expert here at the club
yeah I didn't get to do the cheap
tactics oh I'm lost
okay it's the same person who calls
himself
kramnik student I assume so
maybe please I'm Mitch Meister someone
named Michelle goes play Mitch might
know okay yeah maybe yeah maybe it's
Michelle why this dream is not in
YouTube - is that even is that possible
can we stream directly to YouTube so we
can do that in the future okay we could
do that if we want to I think sort of
the general thing for now is we're
deciding if we want to put them up on
YouTube so far we've done - we put it
both up because they're relatively good
and we want to get people into it we
won't necessarily always put them on
YouTube so watching live on Twitch is
the way to go if you have that option
we'll see how today's stream goes and
maybe it'll be on YouTube at least at
least the bar portion pretty sure that's
what Esserman says about this if they
don't fall for cheap tactics well tough
yeah pleasant illusion that sounds about
right
so I am NOT a huge proponent of the Mora
gambit that just feels like a pond
blender
keep doing it though i hain't can't stop
I have a proper charge get him
okay manic student very tough all right
Jay Matthew he's got a lot of extra
vowels in there thank you for the follow
gladiator chess I have some doubts about
just becoming more popular than for
tonight I have some doubts but I think
what he's really saying is we should
give up on Cheston and start streaming
for tonight not that one Wow
brilliant no no super strong you're the
best what's going on here I made a very
dubious dubious up-and-comer please no
suggestions for four moves i but I liked
some of the yeah there's simple ideas in
here but I don't I don't know if they
[Music]
yeah no worries up and go Ryan's winning
I call you my coach
ah bumblebee wait so we need more sound
on here cuz I don't act well guess it's
a follow so there's no sound biome hear
any sound at all also I can kind of see
the chat slightly this is the mix for
that chat is it worth just taking it
down they might even make sense because
if we're gonna upload it to youtube
later right what's that do you guys have
regular life chess accounts yes we do
what is mr. Loomer what is your uh I
guess what are you playing about three
minutes what's your blitz rating on on
this website hold on um my blitz rating
is uh it's a little lower than the
club's rating I'm there's a big gap my
my rapid rating is like seven my high
seven teams and my boots rating is like
high 15
tough what yeah what's happening - I
just straight down her figured out yeah
moral maniac don't trade down shrines
Flynn are you going to do a thirty part
series on the Sicilian opening explained
so I guess I've kind of moved away from
the opening dude I would like to do it
it just doesn't fit with my lifestyle
now that I have so many children and we
got Jim McLoughlin taking over the
opening of class I would like to do it
maybe I'll do opening stuff and I have
twitch now is my new platform so this
year you'll be seeing all I know maybe
I'll bring some opening stuff which
doesn't always have to be playing people
in twitch it can be opening stuff that
can be people doing tactics it can be
analyzing English game so you guys
submit it could be a lot of different
things so I think we're quite new to
this twitch thing but there's a lot of
potential here for us to do a whole lot
of different things so we'll keep
exploring things for under construction
we're figuring it out you know just get
better and better I might be losing this
oh I'm definitely losing your does the
room you don't lose Geoff's
genome next your name dude you're strong
yeah no no how many kids do you have I
have three children I have a
six-year-old boy and two girls aged
three and one okay
anything last
so we should be five minutes or so away
from the arrival of mr. Koh bein very
exciting yeah I'm actually surprised
remember how many people enjoyed the
very long series can I did the ten part
thing on the semi sloth I'm actually
surprised a lot of people have told me
they've watched the entire thing I would
have thought maybe that's a bit too long
but people did like it so if I do return
I would probably do a long series that's
short
yeah right yeah thirty part on the
Sicilian yeah and that's like barely the
night off right barely like we just
covered the main lines yeah a new
section exchange or something good job
okay is chess club your full-time job
yes I work here full-time I'm the
assistant manager here long-form content
is having some sort of revival on
YouTube yeah it's which is pretty cool
this is getting worse
it really is series it's my personal
favorite thank you cold rayon the bot
fennec seems like the most fun opening
in all of chess and I do agree with it
no one I can play regularly I mean they
sometimes they're better than the
illegal ones so you got a try for that
white King yeah you say that I trust him
Dennis the roof there's deep ability to
convert this despite all the odds you
know I was right don't try Queens what
are you doing
I kind of live a little bit oh good game
okay thank you
mmm Danny you want in on this yeah
Kramnik student who Eric owns on the
he's like watching us yeah cool okay
we're up 240 for the game we've had that
was something similar to our peak of
yesterday's okay yeah Ezra Suman we're
starting you more and more people and we
are we probably have time for for one or
two more games here before mr. Cobian
shows up why are there no lectures in
the past couple of years
by the way fronts yeah I started working
a lot more during the days also at some
point I was promoted to assistant
manager here which means I'm sort of the
Monday to Friday 8:30 to 4:30 kind of
guy so I've started working in the
mornings and that means I can't be here
at night to do the classes but I do have
interest in coming back and and for now
I'm just getting back into it by doing a
little twitch playing with the people
we're playing oh you found him okay so
this is the shawl
this is nachalat oh okay what's up
Michelle I don't know if it's odd but
coming to charlotta who's a regular here
assistant to the regional manager yeah
more those reference to the office you
oh wow look at you I know that's that
mister over here is he a GM oh that's
the rule
not quite a gym but yeah bar Akopian who
is real Jim will be here and
theoretically two minutes in practice we
did it so many times
where's this guy Noriyasu minutes
giorious he's doing mysterious
grandmaster stuff what's your feed a
rating Dennis and doesn't have one
unrated you have no idea how satisfied I
am that you caught that reference sir
yeah watch the office it's been a long
time since I've actually watched TV did
you guys see the video with the Dutch
rules yes you can also see for those
that haven't seen if I was really good
at this I could send you with put a link
here in the chat but I look up our I
guess one thousand hundred thousand
subscriber
whatever it was we made some special
video was that for a 10k video ten year
we made a video where you guys can see
that all the funny moments you might get
forked what's happening jack you saw
right through it your genius
no I'm rushing him you win
okay maybe on the like I mean I calculus
is it Jill Dennis this is a joke I'm
sorry spoken I really question over here
one game he's crushing everybody come on
this guy's good dan it's the route yeah
Dan this is the route that's what people
chant for some reason whenever he walks
in the room each of you who's your
favorite player all-time tough the
official Club answer is Bobby would you
rather have 2700 feet a rating overnight
or have the power to turn warm beer into
cold beer with your hands I got 2,700 I
drink beer once a year that's how much
beer I drink for the record and it's
during the Super Bowl of course so in
February I will have two pints of beer
one per half and yeah that's the extent
of my drinking not a big drinker
yeah yeah most people seem to want the
the rating more than the beer power
they'll teach their own
once a year equals never stops
I feel like I'm the only one asking the
real questions here yes thank you smoke
craft for asking what we all want to
know yeah well that is not a check I was
taking his pawn no you could take it
with your bishop because on his official
bodega yeah but I'm already down to Oh
No why I stopped at beer just not much
of a drinker
I just don't personally enjoy it you
want battles with Ben Feingold not
literally just on chess yeah we'll see
how this channel progresses as we get
our twitch gone
will it become a chess battleground only
time will tell but I don't see any
reason why if there's other you know
streamers out there they want to battle
with us and such that we couldn't do
such a thing actually is a cool idea Ben
is a legend yeah yeah but I'm sure
there's also uh to be cool other people
are streaming I guess Ben's a streamer
so we could play him we could do
simultaneous streams with him and
whoever our GM and Reza's at the time or
something if he's up for it we're up for
it worked for anything at this point
are you a teacher yeah I teach kids you
teach kids when's Akopian coming two
minutes ago
allegedly I don't know what he's doing
sounds like important grandmaster stuff
hopefully this stream features them as
it is called challenge
okay turn calm and good game my turn all
right go get drew all right what's going
on ah some three mini-games all right
what's going on five minute whoa whoa
big stretch you see any five minutes
here did very choppy did we not get it
from the game is that the deal
yeah gladiator I am my gladiator okay
Ivan he's been quite active in the Czech
gladiator chess
let's give him a go higher rated than us
know me yeah what to do against
gladiator okay let's just play this
against whatever setup he does okay
let's do some chess here
I developed a castle I'm strong Chester
okay we got some random position here we
are doing great
[Music]
random maneuvers keep shuffling lots of
shuffling our pieces this guy is very
extreme dota very preoccupied with the
exchange French um what we're doing here
in this position randomly shuffling our
pieces back and forth idly masterfully
remaining routine in control of the e4
square sort of brilliant maneuvering
here it's quite deep stuff actually yes
I'm gonna partner to a strong you are
the best you know I just want upon
hopefully no tactics please Thank You
amber thank you very much maybe I'll
trade more later when you're up stuff
trade so what they say yes yeah yes then
we do it
yeah I didn't know which way to take
back here let's sort of issue yes why
not
well yeah what's wrong with rookie for
something's wrong I don't know yeah
keeping that score for my night seemed
to make sense
alright what this night ideally if I pop
them in here then I'd be doing well
don't know how to kind of six here no
way there's a pin here I'm gonna take
this one he's gonna push that though I'm
just gonna luck this up for a second
yeah okay are you gonna have the legend
Yasir cero on in this dream I'm sure
it's um yeah um yeah he's not in town
right now mr. cr1 oh yeah we'll get him
in here we'll get everyone in here
that's the law
twenty-two challenges yeah this is crazy
cuz you gotta like go way down the page
you can't that's crazy that is all thank
you guys for all the challenges fine are
you hyperventilating I'm calculating
doesn't calculate okay got it
how long until starts paying you guys to
stream there lol I don't understand I
don't know so I quit joste oh okay how
bad is it that I want to survive to get
this square do this how bad was g54 told
me no it was genius
thank you
why did you do it um you know jumping in
here when he's not looking
I'm also second here when he's not
looking I got all the plans okay but
he's gonna go here so b5 I don't know -
chillin I'm chillin chillin nothing's
happening
why have you not played have five at any
point here just cuz did you say it I'll
do it
well no cuz im sue out of three games g5
creating lift
yes very chess classes online from yeah
well they think they're talking about
you yes you might be talking about
Dennis was another of our our good super
saying you'll be doing the beginner
breakdown class yeah he's filling in for
the legend Mike comer had the beginner
breakdown slot it's never play f6 coming
in Mondays
this next year Mondays at 7:30 Sunday
yes that is correct
hmm I'm just I know what they're
misquoting a Feingold rule I can't
chillin like a vanilla bean don't know
that one
well I don't know what I'm gonna betray
my age disconnect here I don't know what
tilts is the otaku bottles you know when
you like lose a game or something and
then you start just playing horrible or
it's from poker okay so yeah sometimes
you lose a chess game and then you just
go until I really didn't get to take
this to be like like it I can't I can't
resist I dig it if I I'm taking us you
mean strong and cuz endearing then yes
that's what Mike is yeah alright sorry I
couldn't resist the temptation I are not
- I've been tilting since I started
playing so what's my plan here good
question now I have an idea then we're
not let my car - yeah he does mr.
checkmate
yes checkmate even better
yes 42 is funny I'm gonna take a good
game for a second I'm gonna go look for
VAR do you want to just all fill it here
somebody will find this guy round him up
so yeah stay tuned we'll be back with
Markovian
okay who gets it here
all right
so I think we're all about the rated
games here guys
good luck iris change up in the
seventies
that was a slip but we're gonna make
this work
Knight f6 was supposed to be
we'll make it work time for the one
drink
dude I I'm Alice lived s six instead of
Knight f6 so I think we're just gonna
get a little bit silly here just a
little no everything's fine yeah I
believe in myself
no they requested the bomb cloud mm-hmm
well not the no wandering King sorry
guys that's what we're hi accidentally
smoke craps comments the funniest yeah
he's real heat fire yeah he's got where
is he very good yeah hey we can't
retreat you okay I we cannot I've been
tonight on mission to play King f8 okay
alright so just develop your stuff just
malicious stuff dude wait the blunder
that he did not play f3 in king fu right
Wow very good
we're friends for reasoning
what's up ponds there's the one Jess one
six four please no no give us moves okay
oh he's saying how to play them he's
only got four minutes 20 seconds left in
a five minute games like him good advice
oh my god you said my king can't retreat
yeah they can't you can't that's not
very manly I am sold on this what's
wrong Bionic younger stuffs in me too
I'm five oh yeah don't tell him but I
plan on inviting him for jamming
residents next year which as a secret
don't tell him that we cool
hmm yeah yeah yeah yeah that would be
awesome yeah that would be awesome
blitz games commentary
what school what's going on am I losing
stuff that
they're talking about you you play Gary
yeah I bloody how do you think I did get
to play a game in 20 against the legend
GM Kasparov this guy is it all the
commercials master class he played the
appearance against me he had black
pieces just just for fun what am I doing
here well yeah so we will definitely
have a lot of our our instructors
included you know we'll get Dennis
playing games in here this next year
again you have to play again so you
don't feel bad this guy also he does
okay well this one good game we got 21
so yeah you gotta pick a new person all
right come on No mathemagical
control yeah
five oh did we play drafts bro yet no no
but that's a funny name drops like hmm
okay well what am I playing
should be for that's before yeah we
gotta played before he getting so
perfect I never played before in one
Raider game and you lost
no I crushed it like a 1,400 Wow my
crush was a tough though before it's
great I told they no theory that's not
great hmm you'd probably get away with
before for a long time
yeah and for you get punished or never
again what that mathematically it's
following us yeah I wonder they have
other animations of a zombie Cobain
isn't coming yeah we're worried we do
have our best person scouting them out
so no that's right oh yeah we got our
best person on it yeah that next stream
is a play magnet that's sick American
Armenian babe um all right but we're not
gonna let him get away
he's got to come play come on Todd will
be an ass to play okay
what's happening you guys are great we
don't need mr. Akopian well well we are
great so - is mr. Cobian yes he's very
stronger at a blitz - he's actually
really good of us so it would be good to
see him this in the spirit oh thank you
gonna be for the I know yeah
well he hasn't canceled there is no
checkmates not real that's I mean you
know it might work but we play some
other movie for I love okay your
triangle okay I don't know if it's a
good or bad move but you can't do it you
triangle system okay all right I'm just
saying we need a third chair in here you
go get one yeah just run over him okay
well now I yang since he committed to
this I coach says no that was terrible
then we'll go dad all right that one's
bad get the one from Tam evil but the
move okay who is the third person you
know I'm the only good midair mystery
man that's the last one the guy is a
mystery break it all we need a Cobian
angry yeah kills me with a tactic or not
there's no tactics you know is his
favorite openings I mean the French yeah
some sort of exchange variation of
something and there you go it's very
solid yeah that's how he'll beat you I
hope this exchange stuff yeah then like
what's it sequel yeah yeah a pawn or
something there's the better player
woman yeah that's usually mr. Ramirez
mm-hmm do
schools he's doing some passes and Josh
games but he still ones yeah so that's
what happens once you get an equal
position there player usually wins not a
step down Wow
thank you I'm great I know we've danced
the rule so what happened master
Lopez you can beat a grandmaster with
the Rui Lopez
yeah if you're really really strong
when's Akopian coming in mind
oh the ready opening is the best opening
change might change his mind um yeah
that's great no opening changed my mind
I don't Merry Christmas you guys please
help - uh-oh Chris yep likes already
right she's yeah main proponent uh yes
there's a lot of different directions
that can go don't do one of those
openings you do for life because there's
a lot of variations a lot different ways
that I can move it seems to be popular
into juniors tournament yes yeah
especially ssin and there's you can go
yeah hard to play people don't pray
again as much everyone preps 344
industry 97 with a DVD on the ready
didn't you we're trading these guys I
can't that's an encounter argument I
mean Kenny said it's yeah okay I take it
all back what does alpha say about ready
yeah that's the best the answer was a
good argument is dead so I mean like
yeah you can't play ball Magnus played
ten games every Lopez yeah you guys
liked about my chests what do you guys
like about it
everything is growing on me it's growing
on me it's really improved over the last
like couple years yeah and also we
haven't have an account here so I
suppose we have a chest a calm account -
yes we the whole point of this
we'll eat up I want to Bishop Elfie
everyone please go cows then we should
play on chestal I didn't catch you if
you want it's your life I know it okay
okay I just move ahead okay a big
special coffee expert yeah I've been
playing at this dream because he's not
let me see his real super secret prep oh
yeah dance the room being special coffee
Magnus learned from him oh okay alpha
zero like the ready and two English
better than efore well okay that's
saying anything though
yeah develop your stuff yeah your nights
not in the game but they're not then say
what d4 falls on that list likes it
better than efore it likes it better
than e4 but it's thirsty for open source
chest sight okay yeah do you play f5 or
Bishop g7 line security everything is
free
tough game here against mr. dress bra I
[Music]
know very tough game he's playing well
strapped he's dead no open source you're
opening up guitar sure yeah it doesn't
really do the English can be yeah just
fine hanging continue yeah this is deep
plan it is no plan well don't give me
lose maybe you're just gonna wait 36
what if I mean Jonathan you can cheat
twice Wow talking about dance the
woodpecker over there the only real
tactician we invited Axl Smith over but
he was unfortunately busy with something
else couldn't make it this year yeah
maybe it's your son or daughter recently
or something yeah yeah yeah just slash
work
what's going on in the security garden
are you thinking let you know okay they
never expected
okay but he wanted yeah sure let's check
then you don't get checkmate it I'll do
my best not to his rook okay now don't
get checkmated whatever you do please
just tell me got a shoe that I could
check me out does that have this is that
possible smash your head against a
wooden chess board just move I need
adults move wherever you want ex okay
I'm flagging I get it go fast fast fast
get your other work in the game you must
move quick fast yes fast hurry
counter-attack him to join the challenge
yeah challenge us on we're on my chess
challenge st. Louis chess club fast and
yeah hopefully the goal is to get var
here at some point if not with us sorry
world's fastest mouse it's too fast for
me I can't take it we can switch out the
old man come on all right you guys
public demands I gotta go home boys the
screen master just challenged English
just click my munches okay 24 challenges
remain
that's too many strong slide this okay
well good very very respectful thank you
good games it's not the real kings
crusher good game
what new game pianist some strong
players but come on five oh please
biggest master movie not done know what
does have waited just really weird for
me
Wow we need to variation this thing you
know what's that all right yeah no I
don't know about this opening so there's
a branch s is better for black cuz that
three has been played I might trade the
bishops I love trading you know the
French now a good place this is Phoenix
he might know what he's doing I'm just
gonna
strategic victory so it can't be that
bad oh yeah I mean it also plays so we
were queen and quite a few other
openings so yeah but Magnus did it now
so now it's extra cool you saw guys the
Magnus play-doh to play b6 no no oh yeah
yeah no well but he lost rate yeah he
played with black side every time the
super guys lose what's college-mate they
just go well yeah yeah but that's only
because I made this little mistake that
almost a get super playable way you
played he played it with black he played
is e45 and they move something like we
need something right yeah rumors what's
happening here hey pay attention to this
game has a good question what doesn't
I don't play f6 I got to worry about
this guy a little bit no no there's
pretty much break it open
check it out challenge means we can
discuss the game in chat is this a
casual one this is rated super ultra
rated ulcerated I've never seen him play
it and classical though
what's happening this is kinda scary
so some portion of this has been miss
bleeding
okay
not a single problem that's single
problem no problems
I'm not worried then hello Cobian ya
having trouble locating that guy huh
we're tracking them down but uh thus far
unable to connect with mr. strong are
you at playing chess who's that question
for ya Jonathan isn't the strongest no
not at this time of day I can benchpress
two works
no this isn't particularly good for me
I'm fine
bustin I found out that you're dead
alright what can you do Joe yeah yeah
but uh yeah we can pretend where someone
wants to know your light chest yeah use
her name don't worry about it play the
dragon next game yeah but I take that
over those he find Fabio
fine Tafari and said so yeah we should
yeah we could obviously change it I was
kind of joking around that we could you
know change her name to whatever
interests but uh you know play Fabi but
uh no verse he's really here
he's coming we're not lying spider does
he even know what
[Music]
yes more has arrived or has arrived
you want to clean up this mess for me
bar is here everybody we're all excited
yeah that's sort of the way it works as
we go yeah go what's going on
bars here though you'll get in live
stream you can play whatever you want so
we got there's like 24 peoples that are
challenging us so they're watching us
here so I'll scoot over here in just a
second so that you can just play yeah
just play as long as you want I know you
got the the classes tonight and whatever
so yeah
ah thanks Josh rod which subscribed with
twitch crime watch there but yeah then
you'll be over sitting where I am when
you when you start playing so the next
challenge is for var so if you're you
were here to play bar he is here mm-hmm
guys tricking me
don't you
I really like this
I want to send a challenge but I'll be
at the very bottom so I go go turn well
you never know who knows how far we'll
determine who he plays does he ever
prefer time control we do have to ask
him this
what's the meaning of his name
yeah so it's yeah good to see if our you
know no it's just a bit of a mess here
quick play of six until you stop me -
just get me out of here - five six with
the rook tonight my queen Oh genius yeah
super works we're winning
yeah so the next game will be far so
he's excited yeah you'll play wherever I
am Oh
take 1 GC 94
what's up yeah so yeah we're too busy
screaming yeah we can't he doesn't have
time for classes anymore what's
happening I don't really know what's
happening if he goes here 70 no 154
yeah so what's the time control so it's
kind of whatever you want it to be
keeping rate of moves so there's always
challenges so they've challenged all
whatever but uh if you tell us what it
is
if you tell us what you prefer plus two
maybe three plus two okay so Challenger
he goes to Ma so oh yeah yeah yeah so
the reason Danny's Mouse - so alright so
we lost a big deal and I want to play
anymore let's give our in here we got
this haven't lost a game you Wow yeah
how many you please we give we'll give
it to this guy we'll give our in here
thank you
the biggest master first one to take me
down yeah played really well all right
let's get bar in here okay so yeah do
three - yeah you go here you know I'll
do my favorite part which is just chat
with these good people here so click on
the challenges there some words yes you
got 26 now and three - so there's a
three - yes anyone you want yeah do the
check so mathematically who I believe
has been in the chat city plus four
right so yeah three plus four rated
okay so you got us here out of 1600
rating we'll see how high we can go in
and we're so oh yes we could kill
challenges but whatever we'll leave them
there because you never know our mood
might change from three to two something
else
it's the interesting most NES yeah right
futures and yes so he hasn't unlike not
fast but it feels really fast and just
feels different
operates all right central ducks hi
dress thank you for following how do we
challenge you go to lie chest and you
challenge st. Louis chess club to a 3-2
game rated is preferred but it doesn't
have to be h5 has been called
disrespectful don't nothing felt that
way to you know position is costs at the
moment it's not so easy to do much it's
really depends on my next one what my
opponent will play I'm ready to open it
up now but
folksy uh saying we should add a command
challenge this I need Danny for so when
someone types challenge the instructions
are automatically posted okay yeah yeah
we got to get into all this stuff
Irwin ripping drop thank you for
following explaining all right
okay pay the right move you see if I was
very important move Kobe and it's like a
hawk ready to pounce on his defenseless
clueless prey
plug my mouse next game okay yeah
religion I have like a simple one like
one okay Wireless ah
there seems to be a lot of the talked to
in the chat the last couple days has all
been about like which mouse you want and
stuff and yeah we're changing up the
mouse
these buttons here right what this
buttons for dating game early you are
this h3 pong could be weak you know
attack it was wondering why you let it
go away there but now you might just
take it yeah so we've done two so we
might get a stream he played the people
so I guess our running segment name is
play the people so this is vara Cobian
plays the people episode 1 something
like that and this Mike did one I did
one and now today's so so yeah you're
the first GM to christen our account
here so we can justify having this is
golden GM next-door neighbor have you
guys heard of Komarov chrome extension
for lie chests
yeah I think that's where he says all
the funny things yeah a pleasant
illusion knows what's up
see anything when he does it he always
has these like funny extensions Cobra
Cobra yeah Bishop sparrows bishops yeah
yes yeah I'm just one for Maurice -
Maurice Ashley has a extension
crumblin yeah that's no fair when they
play well nowadays it's hard you know
it's hard to win big no it's like I'm
supposed to just make a bunch of random
moves and then they just lose
oh yeah so this will be sort of a
regular thing this next year where we
get the streaming so we'll got the GM
doing it once a week I'll probably do it
once a week
hopefully my comer does it once a week
yeah it's very popular streaming
varieties yeah why did the players they
stream right I used to HS in my chest
and also kids to plop so yeah we do have
an account there too so if it was for
some reason your your preference we can
also it's my actually first time playing
here
making us work here no come on today's a
farce first game should be a big crush
where is Mike Mike's on vacation Mike is
so normally I'm hoping to get Mike I
have to talk to him about it first
obviously to do streams on Fridays you
should obviously get the best spot
because he's my comer um any tests to
work on Fridays but he is on vacation
for the rest of the year so there'll be
no more more Michael no ma'am I covered
this year for January he's back he has
to come back Big Mike is back lots of
vacation time so and you orbit all the
tournaments you end up working a lot
more than 40 hours a week and then you
get a lot of vacation time
yeah bumblebee a big fan of mr. VARs
lecture spear goal tease thank you say
thank you
yeah but you have like uh do you have
the most you thought you might have the
most YouTube videos on our whole channel
in the channel yeah I mean it's been
fine gold might be close but ya know
forest right up there he also has a
million view video Yod beginner openings
so very popular home to be I think it
did 1.3 nice yeah 1.3 million not too
bad good Kingsolver having some trouble
joining my friend my Chester name is st.
Louis chess club
it's important not to blunder the first
yes yes no we got really good until you
get warmed up you gotta make sure you
don't blunder
under Monday big fan loves your your
teaching style thank you
and not sure if there's a been Feingold
version of the Chrome extension but that
would obviously be a funny one
things are looking good now yeah okay
yeah maybe it's resigned time but I
didn't expect it
okay I'm gonna go grab the mouse
favorite GM to play with do you often
play online it's all just that calm when
I play going there
playing online that much yeah I also
teach online yeah I already at the
moment yeah just one second okay
yeah obviously we need any Mike comer
extension that is for certain lie chess
is better just that calm yeah they're
both both kind of good for different
things
Gigi yeah well very well-played game
here by math magically yeah we'll see
yeah yeah I'm gonna grab you a good
Challenger so see how many there are
Wow oh wow barely know the rules one
minute come on something different than
that alright I randomly choose casual no
I almost had you all right here you go
chessmen jack
okay now I have my mouse there we go
it's all different story now this should
be easy crush with the right mouse yeah
people have been asking for variants in
every stream - it's not what we're up
for it today but I don't know anyone at
the club that's just like huge on
bearing ups but it'll happen at some
point I'm sure what do you play any
variants or is it all chess no not too
much
I mean I played live it you know
backhouses with my students doing this
every which way we could do on a stream
just like my back house and a little bit
of Fisher and I enjoy Fisher and the
memory is very interesting I would play
a tournament like that if there is like
a live tournament I've taken once
actually in 2007 there was a tournament
in Spain and you did a really big prize
fast it was like a rapid tournament and
then after the rapid was a official
random tournament who is the best person
on was there or less give unchoke shiro
a lot of like big big names over there
so I really enjoyed playing Fisher in
them hmm
so I know you can play online to this
stage yeah yeah so you can yeah you can
play on here - a few we're really
inclined yeah probably stick mostly just
just today yeah what's the exact
username so it's st. Louis Chess Club so
if you're watching on the stream you can
see our name if you look up I guess it's
for you guys it's in the top left and
the top right st. Louis chess club all
one word actually won a 24 hour
livestream of mr. vara Feingold yeah
people are interested in matches with
other like streamers and stuff which
would obviously be a cool thing to do at
some point yeah I am hoping this is
super unconfirmed but we do some on
Martin Luther King Day cos we're close
to whatever we can do like a stream of
fun or it's like an 8 hour stream where
we get everybody you know everybody does
like a two-hour shift or something
mm-hmm which i think would be a cool
thing to do I think it's January 21st
looking into making that happen so no
promises but yeah
really long stream or something would be
pretty cool yeah ultra match against
Andy tang yeah whoa
face chess with the thousand dollar
donation to charity
nice yeah so somehow they can donate in
like a baller or bits whatever it is
thousand bits charity so I think that's
like ten bucks I think it's a cent a bit
I don't really know how it works but
they can do it to charity which is also
cool so that will goes to Direct Relief
and they're now over 400,000 and it also
puts face chest as our number one bit
donator and thanks teamwork for the
follow thousand bits very different than
a thousand bucks yeah
my apologies bid equals one cent okay
that was kind of my general guess mm-hmm
so that's like a $10 this position
actually I played against Carlsen last
year very similar the world a blitz
championship mm-hmm and actually right
now there is the world rapid
championship going on and I've been
watching that today and watching the
Carlson game Nakamura game did he come
back a bit today Carlson come back they
hit it he lost one game but he had a
good day over really got four out of
five so he's only half a point behind or
tomorrow is a huge day it's the last day
and he still catching it first yeah I
mean he's only half a point behind with
five games to go so he's still in it
this he caught a big break in one of his
games against her and Malcolm young mmm
I think the Selden gave myself today
yeah it was
he was down a exchanging of the Saudi
house and completely lost yeah and he
got a huge break there and he won the
game yes good too after that he won a
lost game too so
so I paid this position against him it
was funny he blundered the piece but he
was a blitz game and I missed it it was
like too happy just won the game which
is like a piece okay looks okay for
white it's not it looks okay for me to
do mm-hmm it's all about knowing the
ideas here what to do you know what is
black trying to do I mean actually
exchanging some pieces is not bad for
black here it's actually helps me
because little bit of space and now
actually slowly I try to see if I can
maybe what you're breaking space there
and see what I can do
you know I've played quite a few games
like this what's this guy trying to say
this guy keeps trying to post something
but it keeps getting bad I don't see
anything in there yesterday was a big
game actually between Andrew tank and
Magnus it was you know they both play on
here I think Magnus mostly was nonsense
oniisan but yeah there was but there was
some somebody came up with the
statistics of their matches because I
had this big matches apparently and it
was like 152 Carlson and hundred for
injury yeah I still make mistakes it a
little bit more seriously than ways I
just say just playing now I play b5
because I want to get this before it
I've said before I the way you play c4
so that's why I won't even play before
and now maybe take concentrate now we
have some kind of a calls bot structure
with the reverse color
maybe a little better for puck now
already someone just saw a YouTube video
of you today and now you're on Twitch ok
that's how it happens yeah getting a
request for the bond cloud near disky
has positive scores Carlsen maybe yeah
Carlson has a different style in my
chest you'll do touch and touch works
you can touch - it's gonna drag yeah
yeah just in case he played the Magnus
opening and did you see Magnus was
streaming 2014 aged 421 one of his games
obviously he lost the first round in
tournaments second round he played that
h-bomb when a camera so finicky 45 Queen
each filing for scholars made they work
this cannot be good this cannot be good
because now it's gonna be a nice pin pin
it to win it
yeah there you go this is what I always
tell in my lecture show pin it to win it
that's good advice
yeah I enjoy physicians like this you
know where you know it's hard to win
flashy games all the time you know you
also have to play like certain type of
openings to get those yeah like there
was a brilliant game today in a last
round of the rapid section today is a
sweet Peter Svidler our friend who was
here recently currently got mated
actually against Andre key and one of
the tablets bless all so he got me but
it was a beautiful day there was like a
queen sack check check check
filter King appeared on e5 and then
there was a quiet month I just kill the
game so it was like a really really nice
idea
so unfortunately yeah Peter was on the
other side of that nature
yeah Peter this is stuff now yeah it's
95 comes in it's about time we take a
piece these guys are playing well yeah
just min Jack hey thank you I'm glad to
fight you they never resigned when I win
their pieces when you play they respect
to you if that's good
I started playing because of you channel
10 months ago would be nice to see what
I've learned and get a chance to play so
I should meet oh if you see you Sean
Sean Pete oh you see them in there
that's things people don't they have
different names on this website than
they do on on here sorry but okay I just
one you want cool down we got 29 now so
I think these are the newer ones way
down low I'm not sure but okay oh it is
the 2200 plus I barely know the rules
make it like three minutes something all
right let's see it let's play this
okay yeah and they're provisional so
they might secretly be Chiu per diem
level yeah that's the thing that are
they laughing okay things over was
finally able to challenge us
yeah there's so many challenges
rockabilly play everybody yeah so this
actually this was interesting opening
this is play by yeah
Yaroslav Jetta book play this again five
yeah six I'm not quite sure it's good
it's not only you want to get see 588
yeah the 1500 biddies right now I do
nice the capital of Armenia yep now I
will go for a quick knockout this one
will play a little different style we go
for a quick knock offs evasion work
yeah next move is H warring with their
tactics let's see if we can make it work
it's like saying yes yes yes okay let's
see if we can do it you know this
geography okay this is I think we have
to go for , I mean this ma'am this
should work yeah by all principles
goodness it's not afraid very brave very
brave I couldn't
I feel like he's gonna play retreat it's
getting real today okay Yannick avianna
cough three plus two is actually the
time control they play the world blitz
championship which is gonna start on
Saturday and I play there last year this
year they announced it very late and I
already hit in our arrangement to work
for the club but the next year do you
really want to play in a world
championship when he could be here
crushing 1600s on my chests what's
really more fun actually it was a lot of
stress last year because you know I mean
one first round of the rapid
Championship played on and then I played
third round I played karaoke and the
third round I played do down at the Pune
Mario's I enjoy playing very strong
players because it's it's a lot of fun
but it's a really tough very tough
doesn't accept in like ten seconds you
can hit the X and cancel it maybe the
left give him like five seconds so it's
better to cancel unwanted challenges
makes the list shorter and easier to
pick from so you could do that as well
yeah that's just aboard it so that's an
idea if you don't want you can exit out
so this weekend meant because Panamera
I've started streaming recently
come on I barely know their rules and I
gave like three to weave my cover played
this this I barely know the rules
it was very hopeful based on the fact
that they might not know the rules it's
also that's a that's like a 360 Joe
Justin I see a way a smoke craft has
been very active in the chat okay
anything's here's like a 3 to 3 on seen
that name of the Chandler
Kings crusher is on here it doesn't look
like the real Kings crusher but he lets
us know it's the real one in the chat
we'll have to play this against a gay
karaoke and last year in the world rapid
temptation to late thank you for the
follow yeah but the black players don't
like it when you do this so does that
bug you at all it's all about playing
positions you're comfortable with that's
very important in chess you choose
positions that you're you know you're
comfortable with you know the ideas and
you just you just play the exchange
again that's not they feel ok a rare
lime g6 no they always want to play
Knight h5 so you have to be careful
playing you know it's basically to make
sure that 95 is met by the switch to
Bishop is not very effective here on g7
here
and not sure what he wants to do because
you're not really gonna so now you're
gonna play five is this position because
then you end up with the ISO Lonnie I
mean it's it's a really hard position to
play already for him
black already did something wrong I
don't like it too much because I have a
pretty clear plan you know whoopsy one
my plan is quite simple a tree before
94-95
is it possible to become a cm I am /fm
if you start playing at a later age
20-plus or so or is it too late at that
point it's tough
now there's a nice square the c5 school
so the idea is to put the night to on c5
k p6 is played okay but B success yeah
we gotta follow but I missed it
probably
very interesting moment here I have
Quinby three very concreteness will do
it could do it I could do it with
something else but I'm gonna try it
very sharp line it works okay
if we intuitively absolutes it's very
intuitive on 94-95 I'm gonna take one b6
so that doesn't work it takes only four
I'm gonna go Bishop c7 I think it works
I think
um Thank You sabatham for the follow and
someone was asking what is a concrete
move when you make a move attacking
something you're creating a day like I
made this move I'm attacking the problem
b6 you gotta react either you play d5
but that denies your bond is now
following good no all right so we get to
see this idea good yeah so it looks like
I'm dropping a piece but I see playing
well we've cracked over 200 viewers so
that's a record for our new segment now
the queen is under attack
no I which is like huge in blitz now
played Carlsen that's one thing he was
doing he was playing so fast
he was just like small so just like
lightning faster
yeah I'm just trying to understand why
he did that move because it doesn't look
like it's doing much
it was just hopeful
a Ponzi yeah I can take that either five
I have this is when you have so many
options in UK you have to choose one
yeah Slavic change is very tricky very
very tricky not easy to to deal with it
I'm saying is there a format you'd
prefer to receive challenges and time
controls yeah
three to three plus two that's that's
working out well yeah this was just the
fourth this is wrong
in addition to the yes
all right thank you for the game called
rayon cold yeah yes good game very good
game yeah all right here comes the pain
that's some funny there yes that's a
good one
probably someone tough here comes the
pain look at that nice tough one oh yeah
yeah there we go yeah so I've come
really close several times to getting
twenty three hundred on the site I just
can't do it
so are you Clayton Ivan played this
person to my knowledge maybe I have but
here comes the pain but yeah my personal
account I'm like 20 to 80 or something
so this guy's
with typical Queens gambit declined yeah
Queens gonna be declined and of course
if you take on d5 it's a famous truck
Knight takes d5 there should be a dish
of elephant elephant truck but these
positions I place for a long time so I'm
very familiar with dispositions date
lots of games Dede doctor is asking
Danny a question
I assume do you think that the London
opening is good for beginners the
Defiant beginner in the new beginner
[Music]
three
normally here and I'm not never afraid
of c4 c4 I average about five so right
around here it's now black has to figure
out what to do
I've seen this already I'm really happy
I have some scissors you know she's a
spinning your scissors yeah it's called
40 knots not too much but discomfort
Jake on d4 I get take back 94
you always have to calculate some Bishop
f6 ideas we need for jumps the rukon see
it is it it looks like a no-brainer move
you just play it but then suddenly you
have to worry about stuff here
I can do something like this it will not
take very interesting challenges
okay I'm not in any hurry so this will
always helps me to put just in case
position gets opened and now I have this
e for idea when first if C for I'm gonna
play for right away well immediately and
then you know if I haven't it's just
very very strong this is it looks okay
black gets the pieces out but it gets to
the point where it's a position like
this and it's just very hard to make a
move yeah it's easy to make a mistake
very very hard to make like anymore see
Bishop a5 Bishop f6 resigns so I mean
just very hard position to play
especially in blitz okay so it takes and
as I explained that you take back with a
knight in this positions now there is
isolated form and again it's not so easy
what to play
okay I'm not sure if this one was doing
anything but so at least it removes the
piece from the pin yeah we got something
ah five hundred bits for charity thank
you face chess face chest is where our
big donor
oh yeah he's over taking the lead thank
you very much face dress okay it's here
it's not so easy for me yeah please just
let me know your your light chest handle
if you want to play
so let's see here considering tonight at
5:00
good yeah I guess well we started at
1600 were are yup 1700 making lots
progress life and now my queen needs to
be improved so can you try this idea
here
that's real cool the son of people are
giving charity that's pretty cool no
heating day6 fun I think I could have
played better definitely this game's
casual no Thank You PO G for the follow
its lead chestnut light dress yeah I
said in a previous stream I just say the
buy dress and people say I'm wrong it's
just no light chest account just
donating because he's a good guy
Oh g5 if I was always welcome yeah
she is always welcome because it's it
weakens the position tremendously and
the night is already on at 5:00 that
night is gonna be really difficult east
to get rid of here he's trying to do
something yes
Kathy is thank you for the fellow who
was the man next to a Cobian mystery
mystery man my name is Jonathan trunks
hey Jamie comeon and Thank You unknown
for the follow i sat next to you there
snuck into you and passed you food after
a dinner at the sink filled cup closing
ceremony how about a game you know this
guy Patrick Patrick JMT gave you food or
something all right let's see you can
win a pawn Jonathan I watched your video
on st. Louis chess club channel about
the Scotch opening and I've started the
Scotch gambit did I recommend the Scotch
gambit it doesn't sound like me but
thank you you're very cute mr. Jonathan
so can't raise the tree normally we
don't mind trading yeah I love trading
I've been saying that all day on stream
when you're ahead you never afraid to
trade this Patrick guy says you don't
remember me I'm a friend of Jen shadi
you ate a bunch of steak gold format a
video on scotch equals scotch tape
see here elephant
to second increment which is this
all right it's very promising so we take
now we could look behind it yeah yeah
always remember to put to look behind
the passport it should be winning now
because rook is an ideal square I fix
his pawn structure first now I get in
with the king
yeah there's no no flagging that's the
that's the difference in style between
me and bar I just them all about the
flagging because they don't play well
fire plays well so he doesn't mind
trying to play better moves on his
opponent yeah
it's a little bit to the drama and
excitement if you're always in the red
bar
see if
little bit tricky
you don't necessarily have to play fast
get the increment work itself out here
now in this position you'll need to the
Philidor you just got here Lucina yeah
you just go here drop probably not one
just okay all right that was good that
was the big boy
how many more games you got in you maybe
two more two more two more two more
that's two yeah yeah okay two more games
we got find some three to analyse the
real kinks pressure at the air 1480 a
casual though let's play rated let's get
our rigging up a little bit
Oh casual yeah there we go jump up blue
mark a new mo let's go
yeah they good game though yeah it's a
tough battle that last one mmm-hmm now I
will demonstrate one of my pit lines
okay you don't need to light this tree I
don't know this native tree yeah
Armenian just too strong
now well we'll just play there is
someone through one of the Dragon will
pretend that's what this is what's the
point of being first in line if you
choose randomly I don't know who's first
in line
she feels good
Oh people coming in from your event yeah
I just wanted to say thank you great
stream and I love the YouTube videos
thank you so much cuckoo
yeah he's jumped into first he's now
given three thousand bits thank you
so yeah thank you so much top is first
bottom is last okay so top is first top
on the list is the yeah I guess the
first one that challenged you okay over
the top they pushed them down but they
do it it's just really popular in
Armenia since there are so many
grandmasters from there probably means
it's popular yep they do it in schools
you learned in in school elementary
school yeah guys playing quite fast
alright we're good or thank you for the
phone yes you're not familiar with the
ideas and it's a little bit tricky to
play sometimes you're not sure where the
pieces go in blitz especially very
important to know where the pieces go
lifetime thanks so fella let's try this
trick
it's important to get into structures
you know if you get into a structure
that you're familiar with then you will
be comfortable so being able to get to
the positions structures the comfortable
with key opening up the position a
little bit
can all GM play blindfold chess probably
no I mean can play one game at least you
know I've done five games it's
incredibly hard face chess with another
one coming in it's incredibly hard yeah
another big donation from face chess
thank you very much yeah Mariah thank
you for following
you know some kind of a positional
battle here going on give you so tough
Joe 16 thank you for the follow
fine
questioned is PCH when it's kind of
annoying so just question him to see
where's the Queen going this this player
is playing fast so that's one thing it's
just it's very important it's a skill
you develop some people want to play
fast but yeah you can't
well they're fast and bad that's myself
I say if I can't play well I may as well
play first I tried to get rid of this
Bishop because the bishop is consumable
is stronger than nice so here I would
like to take that piece that way I'm
sure now I am safe it's very important
to play safe first okay just kind of
feel like playing in the endgame okay
sure
it's not like it's completely necessary
to smooth but see if our opponent wants
to enter an endgame
no no not interested how could you
resist but there was a little bit of a
little bit of a concession you know a
little bit of a concession you see here
because now see the file yeah the file
is nice because I've looked it Rena
sheesh
some complications let's see if it's
gonna be okay for us this I really want
to get the e5 stage e6 I mean I said
that works out but it could you know is
e5 move here we thought it's the worry
if five is a movie a five is the worry
yeah I think I have something against it
what time control for the challenge will
be doing one more game if you have a 3-2
on there we we might find you we got
something like 30 people challenging us
so you know only one more game left
after this one so let's see here
[Music]
Keith on ski thank you for they follow
and yes so to repeat will be having the
geuman res whoever it is come in here
doing this sort of a thing once a month
so it's really cool - Vargas to kick it
off here we will have other instructors
that you can play if you don't want to
get crushed by grandmasters you can
always crush me or crush my comer dance
the room and the like I'll probably be
doing things on Tuesdays at noon so that
our next stream will probably be Tuesday
at noon someone will do something on
Wednesday James might do things on
Thursdays and something on Friday so
yeah Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
is sort of our basic set up going
forward if you're looking to follow us
but uh but yeah might happen all sorts
of different kinds of the day and all
sorts of different random days so yeah
no mister again
every one place so well yeah
they made me copulate yeah
does that work I take you
too many pieces on the board they know
and now there's a background title you
missed it yeah okay like a chances
thank you sure you know when you were
ahead you want to trade pieces mm-hmm
that's good to me a lazy D thank you for
the follow not Tier one sub face chess
give to the Tier one sub - yerevan yeah
you stupid very generous face chest and
your von have been big they've both
given over 3,000 bits
thank you to both of you guys you guys
have been fantastic
you know close to 250 people watching
that's quite good
in the phone call with two seconds
it feels good
Frank inator one two three thank you for
the follow there we go some will do one
more all right open up the challenges
here we'll see what we get we got one
more someone with three two
when VAR comes back we'll get to it'll
be your lucky day so yeah good game
everyone's playing quite well so thank
you Joe bloom JEP abloom for the good
game there was everybody saying in the
chat that was really not a man playing
please me please me everyone wants it to
be them will give far the chance to
choose looks like new challenges are at
the top okay this King crusher guy nope
that's not three - yeah the next three
to challenge will be accepted here he's
very interesting if he could play while
playing how to choose moves he have arts
been doing a pretty good job
he does he does analyze his games a
little bit as he's going along but yeah
something except that one
yeah everyone's begging to go last but
there can only be one more yeah so let's
picked I guess is whatever the top-rated
one is or you want to find a real good
one because it's last one sure I don't
know if this is real good game played
with more reading they say you can go
down quite a bit there's 30 of them sure
somewhere there's a good one yeah
thoughts will return sounds good
alright thought us you get the very last
game here and then off to pretend like I
know how to end the stream at the end I
don't but I know how to pretend
returned here huh
well yeah if you didn't get your chance
to play today they'll definitely be
plenty of time this upcoming year we'll
be doing this several times a week and
your options your opportunities to play
the grandmasters will happen once a week
typical minority attack before the first
wrongly to create
yeah create some weaknesses hopefully
it's not easy to win it though because
it's one weakness yeah
yeah we have 230 people watching this
yes numbers yes that's the best it's
been this is the third day of this it's
only the third day first day of the gym
and best numbers so yeah there wasn't
gotten better every day
hopefully that's because we're joined
here with bar not just cuz it's our
third day and I always do appreciate the
chat has always just been good every
single day you know there's not like I
have to I don't have to see here banning
people are dealing with trolls too much
it's just been been good people are
enjoying it and you guys are great
some people are insulting mr. Thanos
2077 is not really that high rated as I
assume over time too once you know JJ
was actually in the chat for a while
while you were gone like at the very
beginning yeah oh yeah JJ from sleep so
he was there I thought maybe I'll soon
be in a tournament yeah I think musters
been popping in to say hi excited to see
him after yeah after a bit so yeah he
popped in he said hi
so I thought at some point there could
be some real tough ones today no no GM's
challenging us which is right
how good should you be before you join a
local chess club just doesn't matter
just come yeah if you don't know how to
play there's usually a class don't know
what area you're in a chess club yep
yeah those positions are tricky for
block because of the weakness on c6 it's
just always gonna time up to the defense
you know so it's just gonna be it's just
gonna be always tied up to doing some
kind of defensive ideas Thank You JT do
it for the fellow really want I might be
5 but yes it's gonna take they concede
yeah I don't think people are worried
about you joining the chef's club
because it'll mess up their average
rating that's I don't think that's the
thing anywhere I think they just want
more numbers so yeah join their local
chess club get better at chess and
bringing cookies probably doesn't hurt
everyone plays well yep
then I guess you'll be teaching the one
class tonight yeah is that fifteen
thirty six thirty at six start you doing
this nice 31 yeah yeah you gotta get out
of here just go right away and teach a
class yeah staying busy yeah so how's
your how's your streaming uh been so far
if I have to look at a child right right
that's why I'm yeah just here just uh I
think quality of my play will probably
drastically go down I know people that's
what people do yeah it's just a skill
you just get good at it over time yeah
my thing is just to focus on the chat
even when I'm playing I get crushed yeah
yeah I'm not good at actually when I'm
playing I got a kind of focus on the
game mmm like I know like a friend level
our own ink and just shot and yeah
really focus thing you know it's
important yeah so I never really play on
the stream okay so we have to get quite
a few followers I've been missing
tonight yeah tonight gets to shrunk I
actually probably had a night beat I had
a good move to I'm trying to bring this
night to see first d3 don't see five
eventually my plant has very long time
you know it's very difficult to play
this position for him
Toby don't be afraid to nose well it's
threatening even some threats use tears
again thank you for the phone
like mine I don't see one it belongs
well quite well
okay and game point oh yeah that's what
you dream I'll just okay it's very
difficult
just the tactics here do you take take
already yeah I mean games up a pond
promised if I was just weak
that's good
yeah so our next stream will be on
Tuesday with me at noon Central Time
a sad little chess game yeah no it's
really hard fun until the very end there
yes thanks to everybody I guess
yeah well it's a lot of fun a lot of fun
hanging out with us today playing a
little chess so hopefully we get to see
it again sometime see you maybe next
week yeah all right yeah somehow we got
to end this stream just like this okay
and thank you guys everybody and I will
see you guys on Tuesday see